je suis prof d'anglais et ça c'est ma
classe ou plutôt ce sont mes élèves
ce que la classe c'est la leur ils
décrivent au tableau se déplacent
librement utiliser les ordinateurs y
compris celui du prof
mon rôle à moi c'est de redonner un
travail et les aider en cours de route
en gros je les laisse à prendre je ne
peux pas vous dire si mes élèves sont
meilleurs comme ça je peux pas encore le
prouver mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'il vienne temps court avec
plaisir et qu'ils sont tous actifs je
n'ai pas toujours enseigné comme ça
d'abord parce que je ne savais pas qu'on
pouvait quand j'ai commencé j'étais dans
un bon lycée et j'ai fait coup comme je
croyais qu'il fallait qu'on fasse
je me suis mis au tableau j'ai raconté
mon savoir et j'ai donné les exercices à
partir d'un manuel vous l'avez des
gentilles et disciplinés ils ont suivi
mes cours
enfin presque tout le temps j'avais une
classe de seconde qui me posait un type
de problème le lundi il était très bien
le mardi c'était super et le vendredi
après midi en toute fin de semaine
j'étais invisible alors j'ai appliqué le
conseil qu'on donne souvent aux profs
débutants dans ces cas là il faut tenir
sa classe
fais-toi respecter le prof c'est moi
alors j'ai condé et j'ai pu ni et ça n'a
servi à rien
ils ont gentiment fait les punitions
mais ils n'étaient pas plus attentifs
plus attentif le vendredi pour autant
c'est frustrant parce que je vaux bien
que c'est des élèves intelligents ils
ont envie d'apprendre
le reste de la semaine comment est ce
que je fais pour attirer cette attention
je ne trouve pas de recette qui marche
alors en désespoir de cause je leur pose
la question quel est votre problème
aumont a marre marre d'être toujours
assis à ne faire qu écouter les profs
marre de passer la semaine dans les
mêmes salles on veut changer
en fait ils s'ennuyaient et il sent
mieux parce que l'école fait tout pour
les ennuyer on leur dit et je leur ai
dit moi même dès le départ rester assis
écoutez prenez en note précités sont
parlé de ce que dit l'établissement
respecter la sonnerie pointé en cours
soyez à l'heure dans ces conditions moi
je trouve qu'ils étaient plutôt gentil
il attend le vendredi pour être
indiscipliné et puis j'ai la mémoire un
peu courte
j'étais moi même un élève qui s'ennuyait
en classe être à côté de quelqu'un qu'on
n'a pas choisi de nous lever la main que
pour donner la bonne réponse
écoutez sans faire de commentaire on me
demanderait de faire ça aujourd'hui je
ne le supporterais pas et voilà que
j'étais en train de faire subir à mes
élèves ce que moi je ne n'ai pas de
l'école bref les élèves s'ennuient et
c'est de ma faute
il faut que ça change alors je demande
autour de moi mes collègues mes amis la
famille
c'est les collègues aussi j'écris même à
l'inspectrice elle m'encourage me donne
des conseils
je ne trouve pas de réponse mais j'en
sors nu une certitude
on doit pouvoir on doit pouvoir
enseigner autrement
en collaborant avec mes élèves je suis
sûr que je peux faire un cours différent
oui je demande de l'aide à mes élèves
parce que moi je n'ai aucune idée de ce
que je fais ils veulent changer très
bien la bibliothèque de l'établissement
à une salle informatique et une petite
salle de travail en plus de la salle de
lecture
j'obtiens le droit de réserver le tout
une fois par semaine le fameux vendredi
je divise la classe en trois groupes de
12 au passage les élèves apprécient
puisque les classes surchargées ce n'est
pas pénible que pour les profs dans
chaque espace ont fait un atelier
différent à la préparation de sketches
lecture recherche informatique et tous
les semaines on tourne et il va falloir
que les élèves mettent du leur parce que
je ne peux pas être partout
donc au lieu de faire plus de discipline
j'en fais moins et ça marche
en double objectif clair aux élèves et
en les impliquant dans ce projet ils se
le sont appropriés ils sont même allés
jusqu'à demander à faire de la grammaire
ce jour là c'est de dire que le vendredi
est utile j'exporte le concept dans les
autres classes et ça marche tellement
bien que je me dis mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait pas tous comme ça parce qu'on
peut pas il faudra une salle
informatique et une salle de travail
dans chaque salle de classe et nos
écoles ne sont pas construites comme ça
et en attendant qu'elle le soit moi j'ai
un problème
l'année suivante je suis muté dans un
petit collège et l'établissement locaux
de l'établissement nous permettent tout
simplement pas de mettre ça en place
et puis les collégiens sont plus jeunes
et nettement moins scolaire alors je
tombe bien le garder mes principes par
exemple je ne parle pas à l'ensemble de
la classe plus de cinq minutes par heure
de cours les profs parle trop alors je
me restera par contre les collégiens
sont quand même
plus dur à contrôler son buzz en plus de
discipline plus de cadres je peux pas
les laisser libres ils sont pas
autonomes dont je suis contraint de
garder le contrôle est en place c'est
moi le plus actif et comme on apprend en
étant actif
j'ai l'impression que les élèves ne
regarde je me regarde apprendre ce que
je sais déjà
bref je n'y arrive pas c'est frustrant
c'est tellement frustrant que très
rapidement je demande ma mutation après
tout je devrais enseigné que les élèves
qui veulent pas prendre
c'est un peu facile de se dire ça après
tout les élèves qui veulent apprendre
sont précisément ceux qui ont le moins
besoin de nous ils ont compris
l'essentiel
j'ai pris le temps de choisir ce métier
je ne le fais pas par hasard je veux
enseigner à tous les élèves les élèves
sont tels qu'ils sont si je veux qu'ils
changent
peut-être est-ce à moi de les changer
ils ne sont pas autonomes mais est ce
que je leur ai appris à l'être je
visualise la classe tels que je ne la
veux pas le propre devant les élèves qui
note
mais à quoi ressemble la classe que je
veux je veux les élèves qui ne suffisent
plus le rythme du court je ne veux plus
voir les bons élèves s'ennuyer en
attendant la correction pour qu'on
puisse enfin passer à autre chose je ne
veux plus voir les élèves en difficulté
ne pas avoir le temps de finir leur
travail avant la correction saleh
démoralise je veux pouvoir prendre le
temps avec chaque élève moment il en a
besoin je veux faire des cours
particuliers en cours je veux les élèves
qui cherche je vais les élèves qui
collaborent choix des élèves qui
réfléchissent je veux des élèves actif
je veux des élèves y aidant je veux
l'impossible dans mon parcours je n'ai
pas d'exemple pour faire ça il dit
taraude en permanence même quand je me
lit vraiment hobby favori le jeu vidéo
d'ailleurs si je faisais un court comme
on conçoit un jeu vidéo il ya plus de
similitudes qu'on pourrait le croire
un jeu enseignes des choses chaque jeu
est un nouvel ensemble de règles qu'il
faut apprendre
d'ailleurs les jeux commencent par des
didacticiels la première fois que vous
jouez un jeu vous suivez un cours
quand je joue le jeune apprend les
règles le jeu paul le créateur le
développeur ce point de sport avec un
tableau blanc et d'un exercice tiré d'un
manuel qu'ont expliqué ce que j'allais
voir faire non j'explore le jeu à mon
rythme on découvre les possibilités par
moi même le but pour gagner et claire et
les moyens pour le faire ne sont données
au fur et à mesure au moment où j'en ai
besoin et je peut ajuster la difficulté
en fonction de mes capacités pour être
sûr d'aller jusqu'au bout voilà c'est
comme ça que je veux que mes élèves se
sentent en classe libre de progresser et
confiants qu'ils le pourront mais
comment transposer ça en classe comment
encadrer la liberté de la découverte
alors c'est mon père qui a eu l'idée de
génie faire une carte du monde
oui parce que dans un jeu d'aventuré
vous avez au centre de la carte le
donjon dans lequel est enfermé la
princesse pour être délivré il va
falloir aller chercher les pays du monde
du feu le bouclier du monde de la glace
est la clé de la guimauve verte pour
réussir ma mission je dois aller
chercher tous ces éléments dans l'ordre
que je veux je me débrouille mais j'ai
un objectif à réaliser
alors vous transposez en grammaire
vocabulaire notion culturelle et au
centre vous avez un texte à écrire et
vous avez une aventure pédagogique que
c'est dessine je transpose sur une
feuille façon carte mentale
et je peux fournir un plan à mes élèves
et à partir de ce plan ils vont pouvoir
élaborer en toute connaissance de cause
le parcours qu'ils ont convient de
suivre parce que si on veut impliquer
les élèves
il faut qu'ils puissent faire des choix
il faut qu'ils puissent prendre contrôle
du court en attendant ce enseignants à
fonctionner de manière séquentielle
linéaire quand j'ai d'abord un coup je
mets les éléments les uns après les
autres sont à un ordre que moi j'ai
décidé qu'il correspond à moi et chaque
élément je lui attribue une durée
arbitraire et ce parcours correspond à
au parcours de l'élève moyen l'élève
imaginaire du milieu si je veux que tous
les élèves apprennent il faut que chacun
puisse apprendre à son rythme dans
l'ordre qu'il a choisi alors pour mettre
ça en place
je donne aux élèves à tous les éléments
au début je leur donne un projet à
réaliser et nous décidons ensemble date
butoir tous les éléments qui vont avoir
ton et va avoir besoin pour apprendre et
faire ils les auront tel début c'est eux
qui vont choisir dans quel ordre ils
font les choses sur quoi ils veulent
travailler avec qui il a eu à travailler
et ses choix les engage tous les élèves
ne font pas tout et certains en font
bien plus et c'est tant mieux
mais chacun aura choisi son parcours
chacun pourra aller au au bout de son
projet et tous auront progressé et moi
je les laisse à prendre comme le cours a
été fait en amont
je ne fais plus court cris jeu devient
inutile
et c'est justement ça l'essentiel
comme le cours ne s'arrête
si moi j'avais autre chose je peux faire
autre chose je veux passer du temps avec
un élève pour revoir des notions combler
des lacunes je peux aider un autre élève
aller plus loin parce qu'il en a les
capacités parce qu'il en a envie
je fais des cours particuliers et
rancourt
je ne me préoccupe plus de la classe
mais les individus alors l'expérience
est en cours et on essaye de peaufiner
la méthode
je suis persuadé que ce format de cours
n'est pas une anomalie
on peut changer la manière dont en scène
et ça ne se contente pas la matière et
avec l'arrivée du numérique dans les
salles ce genre de cours va être bien
plus simple à mettre en place
nous avons besoin de tous pour réussir à
l'avancé ce que ce genre de projet ça ne
se montrent pas tout seul j'ai bénéficié
pour n'arriver l'un du soutien et de la
confiance de mes chefs d'établissements
des inspecteurs de mes collègues les
parents
évidemment les élèves
l'important le plus essentiel c'est
l'état d'esprit
nous devons comprendre qu'à prendre et
une activité et nous devons accepter de
faire un pas de côté pour laisser les
élèves à prendre toutes ensemble la
communauté en travaillant nous devons
pouvoir créer un environnement qui le
permet alors collaborons échangeons et
changement